in light of everything that's going on
around this country and with the
violence going on and with the fear of
shootings and the realities of shootings
this is what our officers trained for
a tense terrifying day for some on the
heels of this week's deadly school
shooting in Nashville thank you for
joining us at four I'm Kirsten Joyce and
I'm Denise Valdez parents spending hours
outside of a Clark County School while
police search classrooms looking for a
student they believed was armed with a
gun this happened at Shadow Ridge High
School located not too far from Decatur
and Grand Teton in the north part of the
valley Joshua paguera Joins us now live
with the latest Joshua
hello hello Denise and Kirsten Metro
Police arresting a teenager for what
they say was he made threats and showed
up to school with a gun now Metro Police
are also saying that this individual had
a gun but they haven't located it yet
and the moments leading up to an arrest
was anxious for everyone
all the parents here want their kids to
come home because all the other
shootings oh you're gonna make me cry
Yvette Craig stood outside waiting to
pick up her niece upset she says schools
are no longer a safe haven for kids it's
just you know ridiculous that it keep
happening like this and it's sad Metro
Police say an underage student faces
charges of terroristic threats
authorities received a call around 10 15
this morning of a student near campus
with a gun they were then notified the
student was walking around campus with
that gun Shadow Ridge went into lockdown
Lieutenant Brian Zink was school police
we'd like to ask you parents to please
remind your children about what is
appropriate and inappropriate to say
when they are inside a school building
this entire situation could have been
avoided if the young man had not said
what he said Elvira Castro was waiting
outside of Shadow Ridge for her daughter
I went outside my yard and I could hear
all the sirens and that really scared me
I caught up with her as she reunited
with her daughter you can't take people
lightly anymore if they say they're
going to do something they normally do
do it her daughter Elizabeth says the
whole experience was nerve-wracking my
dad told me this morning too because of
the shootings that have been going
around in Tennessee yeah he was telling
me about that to just be careful when to
be visual in
foreign
police have yet to locate the gun they
believe the student brought to school if
confiscated this would be the 40th gun
Clark County School police have seized
this school year reporting live near the
Canadian Grand Teton Joshua piguero
eight news now Joshua thanks for that
now this arrest comes after we reported
just yesterday that from the start of
the school year to mid-February police
have already arrested 94 students